all right so uh you've heard from mickey
a very high level overview about the
israeli market and i'm going to drill
down to the bottom of the like one phase
within the machine learning development
cycle so um
sorry for that
and uh i hope that you have a good time
to
like fly up and then come back down
so
let me introduce myself quickly
my name is inval and
i joined pando a year and a half ago to
establish the machine learning
department here at pando
and um
i will not talk a lot about uh like our
projects and what we are doing but you
are welcome to catch me in the break
session and uh and uh talk to all the
bundosers around here and myself um but
uh what i would like my my
personal journey i finished my phd in
computer science like uh uh seven years
ago and since then i've been at really
huge companies like microsoft
and uh really tiny companies i was the
first employee of a startup that was
later acquired by an another startup and
they ipo'd later like it i had my share
and
now
the the thing is that
a poc phase a proof of concept phase is
something that
is there all the time for every machine
learning project for every company that
i've been at
and um
i think that there are a lot of
of good things in it and a lot of bad
things and we as data science leaders
i think have um
have to to make it better like to to
make sure that we are uh not drilling
down into like a a one year long poc and
not delivering value and this really
connects to what mickey said that
we are here eventually to bring value to
a company and uh the poc phase can
deviate us a bit from from this mission
and uh i do want us to be like uh uh on
it and uh therefore i came up with this
uh talk so uh let's start and when i
start i really really like to start with
an example so it's an example not from
pendo but something that is very easy to
explain from real life
and every machine learning project
starts with a business need right so um
uh if you have amazon prime or a prime
video um
so
uh there there is a business need there
was a business need they actually
answered it um
when you see like a certain scene
and you feel that you know this actor or
you know this actress
and you just don't remember their names
you know it
how did they solve it do you do you have
it do you use it
how did they solve it
i forgot the name of it it's like he
paused the video and just gives you a
list of all the actors on screen right
right so it's such a cool feature very
easy and i when i saw it at first i
thought wow what a good machine learning
project i have to put it in one of my
decks so
there we go um
and
the business need comes from a customer
pain and the customer is exactly that
like i don't know this actress what's
her name
and uh there's a machine learning after
we identify the need we have like we
identified the machine learning
opportunity and we say okay we can like
we have face detection we can uh like
detect detect the the face in the scene
and match it and find like the the
actual actress
um and this is how it's uh implemented
so when you pause uh the the film
then uh you get to see the the actors
names
but let's assume that
that it doesn't that it's not
implemented like in netflix there
it's not implemented and now you're
working at netflix and they tell you we
want this
so what what
what you're gonna do what's like your
first move
yeah there's a list of the actors
have a pre-trained uh
english classifier
and start a poc right so yeah we're
starting a poc it's poc time
uh
so
this is exactly like my way of thinking
and um
let's pause for a minute and talk about
wait like when we start a poc we have to
acknowledge that we are not like
starting a project we are starting a poc
and this is more or less like a
wikipedia in wikipedia it was very long
i i had to shorten it but um
this is the definition by by wikipedia
it's a a feasibility test okay it's not
a
uh final complete product uh ready to be
delivered right it's a feasibility test
and it's uh it's usually usually small
and may or may not be complete right uh
but the idea is to
to ask ourselves whether we can uh solve
the business problem
uh this customer pain with machine
learning
and um
if we look at the life cycle of machine
learning project we start with a
business need
then we start with a poc
and then we continue we have the model
development and then we have to remember
the phase of the product integration
because like uh the machine learning
model is not living in in vacuum it
usually like connects to some ui and a
back end and a product out there
and uh then we ship it and we forget
about it or we monitor it like it
depends like i like to monitor but
all right so
uh but look at this phase the poc phase
um
it actually after the poc phase uh we
can have two outcomes one possible
outcome is that we say yeah it's
feasible let's continue with development
and then we are like after the poc we
know more like what are the product
requirements we know how to continue
and
the the other option
is that we'll say
no it's not feasible so let's not dive
into development and all this long
journey that comes after
and and stop it on time let's not waste
all our efforts on something that
eventually
it could be not feasible it could be
that the customers are not so interested
in it uh or like any other thing and
we'll talk about it later
so uh this is like where poc
and uh
[Music]
yeah so that's that's a very good
question so the poc is the baseline
model so we have to um to strive to
something very very
basic
and not like
put there the the best model from you
know the the
um
latest and greatest machine learning
article that we read yesterday and it of
course it doesn't have a github
repository we have to
to start it from scratch and like no
let's let's start with something simple
that kind of solves the problem and
estimate whether
we can go further or we should stop
um
so i don't know if you know like the
reference to notorious vig but uh i
liked it i hope you understood it um
anyways uh why why why is it so
notorious like what's the
problems with
with pocs
any idea
maybe
when you go from there
certain examples that work with the
whole set you want to deliberate
customer
yeah out
yeah so you start with it but it doesn't
extend to the whole set right so you
start with a limited data set and uh
then when you hit production then you're
like it's a mess because real life data
is is different than like a cleaned and
nice data set that you collect
right there's also misalignment and
understanding of feasibility the
definition right it can be a reasonably
feasible and great looking in a notebook
but
really not adapted to production
environment
right some technical
issues that may may arise from from a
poc or during a poc
it is mostly not scalable
that's true what about like um
uh like the definition itself for poc
like sometimes we just don't know where
to stop right so
um
so one i i think it's around the
exploratory nature of poc so i'm a data
scientist when i get data in my hands
i'm so happy i'm trying to like explore
everything start answering a lot of
questions that pop up to mind
like
it's it's nice it's fun it's cool i like
i like it but um i'm not really really
very focused on like the the value to
the company and uh the the project that
i have right now
so um
so it's not well defined a lot of times
and uh we are not sure what to expect
what what will i get in the end and it
is
inherited uh to have like a lack of
focus because we do want to to be able
to explore a bit more and to ask a lot
of questions
and um
and it it gets long it's it it could
take weeks or months and uh i heard of
years like a year not more i think um
and uh there's no definition of done
when are you saying yes i've done with
the poc i'm okay with it i'm like i have
my results because you always have
something more to ask or to explore
um
oh so the manager tells you what if you
are the manager and you you don't have a
clue
um
so um
so it and and again this is something
that you have already that it could be
inaccurate because you're showing some
results it looks so promising and
everybody wants it and eventually like
they don't reflect reality so this is
something that you should bear in mind
when you
present it to to everyone around and
yeah this is like a huge problem
so having all that in mind
if this is like so bad
why are we doing it
what's what's good around it what's
what's the benefit
not stuff
not starting right away
more
save money
right let's
let's say i hear from the others as well
right
it's worth it i i like it it's worse if
we don't do it
so i think that
look in machine learning we have a lot
of uncertainty like we start a project
we're never sure we feel like very
uncertain that we can actually deliver
the value that we we promised
um and we need to validate we have some
kind of hypothesis and we need to
validate it and uh
there are always tech limitations
and uh it could be around like actual
that like the machines are not big
enough to to handle it and it could be
something around like the the technology
is not mature enough and if you require
like 100 percent
precision and recall and f1 so maybe
it's not like it's not something that
that that is feasible
and another thing that i i don't know
how to say it but you have to like to
feel the data uh i don't have a better
way to to phrase it but it's something
that we all data scientists understand
um
and it also
um
if we feel around the end
that it's going to a good way like it's
a we are about not to say
this project is a is not for us but we
are going to continue to development of
this project
then uh we can start with effort
estimation of how much time it will uh
take us to deliver both both like the
engineering side of it and both like the
model development phase how much time it
will take
and uh what roles do we need in the team
in order to to have it done
so uh it
helps us to reduce this uncertainty
and then um
on the product side or more like the
business side of things
um
we could show it to possible customers
and ask
do you like it would you pay for it like
eventually it's something that uh that
gives like we can describe it with words
but if you give them like actual
presentation around it or some kind of
demo it helps a lot to con
to explain the value that uh this
feature conveys
and um
also
it can even give us further like we use
it at pando to actually design the user
experience they say
well i i don't understand like
can you add a button that does this and
can you put the colors and would you
have a trendline bar like a chart for it
or things that are actually helping us
in designing the the user experience
around it
and
preparing
the entire project's product
requirements
um
so another very important thing that
not all of us
are involved in but
i'm involved in it a lot and i think
that
my team is also very aware of what we
are doing with with the management
and if you have a good poc and you
collect some customers reviews
and uh you know like that there is a
product fit and you
uh project it to the and present it to
to the management
then you get a buy in from the
management and in machine learning teams
it's it's very important because uh we
need to have a lot of
of buy-in and support from for from the
management because our projects are are
complicated it's not like
a very simple to to bring to life a
machine learning model in production and
we need this support ongoing support
from the management
um
so uh this is also and basically like if
i look at the overall thing
we want to reduce the risk
uh so yes it is worth it to to to start
a poc
and um
from this
uh specific talk uh if you're asking
okay so what's in it for me and you're
still not convinced so i have this slide
especially for you
um is i will give you some
some tips i give you actually three tips
on how to um to start a poc
and some do's and don't do's uh that you
can avoid some pitfalls uh that you
don't want to go into
and
i hope that i'll wrap your mind around
uh how to think of a poc how to perceive
them and uh
it's something that is more you know
it's it's more around the mindset
um that comes with it
so
back to our poc
and uh
i remind you that we are all around uh
finding those uh those actors
um so
as
someone here also said uh we are going
to have two models pipeline okay and we
are going to like real
real life poc right here
uh but we're only going to focus on the
first uh on the first model of face
detection so given a scene or given one
image we're going to do the
the faces the detection
and
i found a really cool github library
for
python engineers that also has like it
has wrapped a lot of machine learning
and especially around images and voice
and processing and
i'll show you like in three lines of
code uh what what i did just there
uh
one second then
like this is like this is the github
repository
um and
this is like the face detection and i
will we'll run it here live
uh i
only did a few changes i added this
this notebook and i just wrapped
a sum function and exposed a few
parameters so it would be very easy and
not too hard to understand
so um
this this is like the default image that
came and actually it it looks cool it
recognized that this is an abba
abba picture
and there you can see that it perfectly
recognizes but this is a not a good
example because this one came with the
package itself so let's start let's
look at another example
um so this is the next example
and uh
yeah it looks it looks really really
good right
um let's go to the next one
all right
well this this didn't go that well and i
found that uh there's a parameter here
that we can tweak
and
maybe it will help yeah indeed it it
helped okay so uh so there is some
parameter fine-tuning but now if we if
we fine-tune this parameter and we're
not going to dive deep into into why
this scale factor has uh helped me
but um but then we have to do like
regression tests like make sure that
this parameter uh
works well on all the other photos as
well so uh and we are not going to do it
uh but this is just for you to feel how
how it looks so uh the
first tip and this is like not an actual
tip here from the presentations so it's
tip number zero
start with something that it already
exists
uh package don't like invent the wheel
for a poc start with a package that is
already there and i do hope that um this
is not news to anyone
so now uh
let's say
okay for let's assume that we have ran
it uh over a few movie scenes and now i
need yeah this back
and we tested it and we understand that
it needs some calibration and it needs
some parameter fine tuning
and uh we also we learned something from
the data so we learned about the types
of mistakes of
boxing
faces
because we learned on a mistake
that
there is no face and we box it or there
there is a face and we don't
put a box around it so yeah okay good
and
uh and now we are coming to the phase
where we are we want to make it perfect
we want to make like
fine tune it and uh and really
um
fit it to our data or shall i say
overfit it's to our data
and
my tvs don't do that all right so don't
make it perfect
because then you'll dive into
finding like the best solution and
finding like the best set of parameters
for a set
that is
not like it's it's just a test set you
know it's it's not real life set there
is the same
right
uh so i know that you want to make it
perfect and i know that like this is
like it hurts it hurts you you see
something and you know what you have to
do but i'm saying okay stop yourself
stop uh
tweaking the model
and uh understand
that this is bad this is bad for you and
this is bad for the team because uh if
you're like diving into long pocs and
trying to optimize everything then uh
you lose trust it's hard to explain what
you're doing you say yeah i optimize
this parameter and then this but this is
like
just a poc
and uh what you want is to get it into
the customer hands even if it's like a
poc an offline poc get it into the
customer hands as quick as possible
in order to
[Music]
know maybe maybe this solution is good
enough maybe customers will say well
this this gives me like okay only three
faces out of four but this gives me
already a lot of value and i'm willing
to pay for it and that's all good yeah
it could be
and um it could me it could be that
customers will say i don't even care
about the results of of it uh but the ui
is so annoying like there is something
else that could bother them and we don't
don't even know
and
and
it could be that they say even if it was
perfect
then i don't want it it's not it's not
something i'm willing to pay for it
doesn't give me any any value even if
it's if the machine learning model is
like 100 perfect yeah but maybe this
applies to products that their core
values know the machine learning or the
algorithmic side right
i think that like in
core machine learning products
understanding whether you can make it or
not may take some more time you know
like any different
company i i know started with a lot of
process tiresome process
fill the funds i know you know this is
one
second and
i mean i like there is like good enough
right
but but then it
doesn't really has to
be some connection with the machinery at
some point right
right right so what uh what
what i'm saying here is that um this is
something of course that every project
and every company has like its own
flavor of things right
uh but what i mean here is that you have
to um
have in mind like the option that maybe
you are diving into something that is
eventually not
not not good enough not because of the
tech not of because because of the
machine learning
and uh you should
try
as soon as possible to release it uh to
not release in in production in
production meaning but
to release it to the customer hands and
and to their management and make sure
that you're on the right direction
then after you you get there okay you're
good
then go and and hit the development
phase
all right
so some do's and don't do's here
uh don't go and optimize the parameters
over like this poc data set
uh don't answer like new research
questions that pop out all the time
during the poc
don't test like
five six ten different solutions
and
choose the best one
instead like state the parameters like
note to yourself what you you can do in
in the development phase
uh list the new research questions and
prioritize them ask the product will
will it be interesting to to do this and
to go that direction that's okay just
list them and
don't like go and solve them
um and choose one simple solution or
maybe two like if it's really not doing
it but but
uh uh you know limit yourself on the
number of the solutions that you are
trying during the poc phase not in the
development in the development you have
to make it as perfect as possible that's
a different story but like in the poc
phase limit yourself
um
tip number two
know your audience who's the audience
who is the audience for poc
who gets the results
the product manager right who else
the management
customers the customers oh you've listed
all three
um
yeah so
these are usually not data scientists
so
know your audience
when
you're seeing it so you can say okay
this is the precision this is the recall
this is the f1 score
they don't care they don't give no like
they don't care
um
so don't
show a python notebook no no no no it's
only saved for these kind of events it's
not for like the customers or the
management even if it looks like very
organized no don't do that um don't talk
about f1 score or auc score it's not
something that people can actually
perceive usually like most of the times
don't uh
dive into like implementation nitty
gritty details of everything that you
have done
um
and
don't portray a perfect image of like
this is what you're going to to see and
this solves everything one hundred
percent it looks like amazing jump on
trade
instead
prepare a deck or maybe a demo if you
have the resources
and um
explain the business value not the auc
but like what's what's the actual
business value behind it
and um this is something i struggle a
lot with because i can talk about the
the underlying technology and machine
learning for hours but i have to like
find a compelling sentence to describe
this technology
um so do
like try to find it
and
do describe the limitations and all the
things that you have seen in during the
the poc phase that could be a problem
it's it's a risk that everyone should
like notice and and this is time for
education like machine learning is is
not going to give you perfect results
and this is a good time to say
listen this this is the case this is
what we can do
um yes
[Music]
let's not dive into it because i don't
have a long time but maybe at the end if
we have time for questions
um so this leads me to the last point
and uh i'll shorten a bit
and uh the thing is to really
communicate the gap to production so
this is how we started it a lot of
people said like the the problem with
pocs is that it's not production ready
and this is the time that you can
communicate it after you finish and you
present your results
um so even if it looks perfect and looks
it looks so promising and everybody
loves it and we present it to the
management i've been in this situation
before
that they asked me
okay uh
ready for deployment is it ready for
tomorrow and i'm like
uh no
and and they asked me why this looks so
great
uh so the one thing i can prepare is
like a real
life example like if if you have a real
world data then um
you can have like this kind of uh of
movie okay in amazon prime and it can be
a very
embarrassing result right
so you don't want that
and um another possibility is that you
have this kind of movie and this is
another very
like this is not the result that they
would expect and this is like real world
data it's messy it looks like
a lot of things that you don't expect
and you should explain it to the
customers to the management to the
product management this is something you
you need to um
to explain very
clearly
and uh scaling is about the data that we
just saw
and it's also about
uh the infrastructure because if we want
models that keep learning from their
mistakes and we have like something that
like online uh training then it requires
a lot of infrastructure
and um
it's not only one model it's usually
like a pipeline a few models that are a
concatenated maybe simultaneously maybe
asynchronously
so
there's a lot of aspects and you should
like explain it uh
all the time in order to like be able to
get this buy in and support around you
um
so basically we are here at the end of
uh this talk
uh so let's summarize by saying tip
number one don't make it perfect even
though it's hard
um and then know your audience
don't like
talk business talk business it's the
best uh it's the best way
and communicate communicate the gap to
production uh
because it's really something that
requires a lot of in infrastructure and
people like a lot of times don't
understand it
and that's it
ready for questions
yeah i'll repeat the question so the
question was how to know exactly how how
much resources we need for
like
to complete the project
this is really tough and it comes a lot
with experience
and uh what you need to do is like first
of all to try to break it and do your
best to break it down into a building
blocks
but uh eventually um
what i do is i give a t-shirt size so
i'm not saying it will take three days
and a half it's never three three years
and a half um but i'm saying something
like a small medium
large extra large
where
uh like smalling machine learning is uh
is the month and i never hit small so
it's always like medium three months
i don't know three to six months
one year and more
and then i never take the extra large so
i'm focusing on the medium and large
like i ever all think about it
but it's it's really hard
yeah
yeah so so what you're saying is that uh
there's a accuracy there's still science
that you cannot
yeah but the accuracy it it has like a
value in it right so it means um
that people in 10 of the times will not
get like the the right actor or they are
not going to get any actor at all so
this is something that you can say but
if you're saying this is uh like a 90
precision then it doesn't say anything
but if you say like 10 of the time
people will not see the expected results
then they can understand it and you can
say with this model i think that we can
get
drop it two to five yeah before like a
regression there is a classification so
it's easy to go i don't know like it's
every case that you have to find the
business justification and it's not easy
always to for data scientists to connect
it
but this is like this is our job this i
i think that our job is also like
because it's such a new field we have
like it's on us it's on us to explain
the business value and to talk the
business language because no one else
can like do this connection it's easier
for us to do this connection than to the
business people
all right
so thank you everyone
[Applause]